hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey look at us we're promoting
Dark Phoenix apparently we are going to
do a reaction to black mirror of the
latest season than the first episode of
that season we'll see how this goes if
you guys have watched it every game of
Thrones ones you know the drill YouTube
only allows for ten minutes worth of
reaction highlights to be included along
with the footage from the show our
full-length stream along reaction is
going to be over at our patreon page
over there we do stream along for many
shows like supernatural Gotham Cobra Kai
Season 2 haunting a hill house my hero
academia attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood one punch man
several those shows have reaction
highlights included those are attack on
Titan one punch man my hero academia
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and
supernatural this one's gonna be a
little bit more of an experiment we
hired our friend Erik over a nerd
chronic please give him a follow he does
work for many people like Iman snow ah
Kazan movie trivia Schmo down he has his
own podcasts on YouTube forever podcasts
were found as well because we hired him
for investments like this we just try to
make sure that we're at least breaking
even in some capacity whether that's
through patreon pledges through you know
if the video happens to be monetized or
usually they're not but if it happens to
be monetize it then cool if this video
does well we'll continue the rest of the
season the the other two episodes is to
test out whether or not this investment
was worth it or not because this black
mayor Game of Thrones was a little bit
more of a guarantee that we could
possibly break even just being perfectly
candid with you guys so if you like this
video hit the thumbs up button you want
to share it go for it let's get into
this show which gives me a lot of
anxiety and headaches
my babies in the role play just the time
and I got to work tomorrow
[ __ ] your work yes I'm eating pizza loud
okay oh damn they couldn reverse the
snap striking fibers ex interesting
striking vipers X it says here you need
one of those VR add-ons I don't have one
oh no black mirror you've done survival
horror now what are we gonna do it vo
good you want to share that with the
class yeah so scared lucky man I mean he
do
he had an affair or something do know
his parish is going great duration do
you see how much they love each other we
should have him open for dinner you
could make you chili play some video
games
sure just ate so much I don't know if I
can go home buddy
it's gonna be fun at first yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is crazy
no are they gay no no wow that respect
is crazy
yeah the way they realize that fight -
jeez
[Music]
oh that must be so confusing yeah yeah
and then sir maybe she just find it
funny actually make out you know yeah I
mean technically he made out with a
blonde chick from a video game no it's
real take care daddy for me okay okay
damn is a kid gonna play I hope not kids
in this world
Oh God hey there hey I can't play long I
saw me too no serious game here we go
hey no right trying to convince yourself
boy it's different characters whoa
interesting its next level roleplay they
foreshadow the wrong way yeah but is it
like that are trying to shutter as the
characters or or are they attracted to
each other's personalities and now they
have a hetero tap into that through the
care about a damn are they gonna meet up
in person and do it maybe
maybe they're gonna realize that they
are soul mates
[Music]
but are they like it like actually
ejaculating in there yeah I mean I I
wonder if me these I mean if you feel
the impacts and stuff you know it's like
you can have a sex dream and you know so
maybe I am the same as that he's totally
disconnected from reality
I know oh this is so hard to watch
that's heartbreaking but it's really
slowly heartbreaking
I feel so bad for her oh no god they're
coming with like an actual relationship
one's a guitar so note the are there is
a whole [ __ ] Orchestra the tunes
basically the same the palm Clementine
oh yeah
[Music]
do you meet up like in person with him I
can't see how you feel
yeah
oh hell happens to be home like one long
heartbreak this is well motions we
haven't done it in weeks I've been tired
mm-hmm I meant to be drying again we are
trying oh you're pregnant if you don't
[ __ ] me Denise
die or do you want me anymore I'll
always want you know you know what I
mean I mean me this this
nothing is going on the balance
you can hide its wings here
[Music]
are they actually get here I want to see
them meet a person about this but I like
that's coming up
I gotta think a few we don't have to
completely cut it off what about like
the first Sunday of each month no just
not with the car it has to stop 11 years
22 years have passed
I gotta get Majnu
no there's too much time left on the
episode this is too good right yeah I
invited Carl over why would you do that
oh gosh
he said you hardly got to see him and
they didn't speak to him at the BBQ
thing that we had horrific I just want
to like walk around what your baby
remembered time that you've got that
Molly and you insisted that would all
take it I hang one quick game while
she's in the kitchen
I try [ __ ] a computer control
characters this [ __ ] shut up it's
like a bird or any sex stuff they just
sort of it didn't get me not like when
we're in there you and me
happy birthday man it's good to see ya
you too Lord hug each other like every
time I watched it I know this happens
someone over square the head this one of
the worst and if he wasn't married this
would be so much different
come on man overcome it offer a comment
don't do it on the hook - it's gonna do
it you [ __ ] I was gonna do it you
know the sake of drama he is going to
turn Oh No
it's gonna be fine don't worry it's
gonna wrap up really easily
we're gonna kiss yes like kiss it's the
only way we got to know you know if
they're fireworks then okay
bang okay
Oh
[Music]
is it
no can a damn thing
not me neither
oh I'll see you back in the king yeah
you know it's different in the game no
you got to keep that [ __ ] out of your
head coming up you know his power right
II know her all right in there man oh
okay Oh knows me
they had a fight I have holy [ __ ]
talk to me they say what the kid in the
car black mirror with a kind of happy
night we're gonna do it in the game befo
what are they gonna do it to you
that's what are they doing it with other
people that you oh what's much
oh I guess in their own eyes they are
ganene once a month they're gonna have a
cheat day okay
but we're list
[Music]
it can be like a sequel episode you see
like what happens with them
naming yeah where they go it's like with
with the couple with Anthony Maggie and
his they're great at taking just
emotional context and making you squirm
the same way you might during like a
body horror sequence well yeah they're
good at yeah I like as much as like icky
and anxiety I feel watching this
specific episode I can't help but admire
the the brilliance and the craftsmanship
of just taking a whole different don't
like you just don't see that coming and
it seems like something that could have
just been a joke when you think about a
catalytic [ __ ] and they're like oh my
god floor it to like a human extent not
just like a joking extent in it yeah
creates this really fast
I love when they can strike the tone of
being like emotionally horrifying but
also like kind of beautiful somewhere
deep down like I I really liked what
this episode tried to do partly because
in black mirror land I just immediately
flashed like the Wyatt Russell episode
when I think of like black mirror video
game this is gonna get twisted and nasty
yeah and this got twisted yeah but in a
whole other emotionally confusing way
and I love that you know without even
being in your face about it you know
it's a you know it's it's sort of a
queer story or like a queer sci-fi story
you know and also starring people of
color like this is cool in general you
know it just brings up so many different
psychological debate like I can't get my
thoughts straight right now one day
you're gonna need to say
like from beginning to end you're just
really good they gotta meet up in person
they gotta see how they feel right
that's that's a gay thing or is this uh
you know or have they been like in love
with each other this whole time and the
heartbreak of watching his marriage just
slowly deteriorate and he's like he's
having an affair
is it an affair is definitely an
emotional affair the rules here I mean
an emotional affair a lot can consider
that the equivalent of a physical affair
you know I'm like this but it is a
physical affair that blurred line of
this whole thing in the you know you're
watching it the cool fight scene take
place you're like ah this is probably
gonna be something he's probably get
like a violin or what or maybe we'll go
into a different game and sing is to get
real wrapped in there's again if we let
the matrix where he like gets injured
it's real ramble is brain or something
or is he gonna start having flashbacks
from the game and lose touch yeah yeah
this erection they took it with with
these uh with these uh these characters
was mightily impressive man yeah well
I'm very very human very subtle like so
much of this episode I really admired
the visual language both just in the way
they shot things and also the way they
capture the performances because even
though I mean you know these black
mirror episodes do rest on a good amount
of clever writing and stuff like that
there is also a good amount of just
visual storytelling in here because
you're soaking in the moods of the
characters yes
the actors are phenomenal they are
phenomenal in this episode I like all
three main characters oh you who played
Theo she's she I'm trying to read this
whole time I'm trying to scroll but for
some reason not properly letting me do
it here well yeah yeah ha I've dual
Mateen who played black mana then you
got Anthony Mackey's character in here
and then of course my Nicky Bihari
yeah that's seen at the table we're at
the restaurant where she was just so
confused and oh yeah I have wanted to
see how he explains the situation me too
because black mirror often does deal
with sexuality passion desire like it's
some other you know reoccurring themes
and then how technology sort of fulfills
this void for us and how it enhances the
different instincts and inclinations
that live in oh yeah yeah yeah because a
lot of this does primarily deal with
sexuality because it's like there's a
lot of confused emotions going on
through all the characters but of course
are two main male leads here there's so
much emotional confusion but by the time
they get to that scene where they do
kiss each other like there's no
fireworks I try to say because the
logical place where mine first goes to
is okay these guys must have just just
yeah just feelings homosexual desires
that they haven't or they don't know
about or something or that they're
deeply you know buried down I thought it
was an interesting compensation to make
where she can have an actual physical
like they formed this weird kind of
polyamorous relationship where she can
have a real physical affair but she gets
the version that like most dudes I would
imagine like most stereotypical dudes
where it's like for her she gets to go
out and yeah I see somebody new one
night a month and hubby gets to get down
with his best friend you know which like
in a sense I guess for a family
environment if you're gonna open it up I
guess is the logically most workable
version of this yeah because there's
that whole other thing to where where
Carl explains like I've tried with other
people I tried it with the computers
I've tried it in groups it's you
specifically my buddy day yeah
you know like and there is an emotional
undertone to to their connection even in
the game like because of their history
there's a such a connection and they I
like how the beginning of this kind of
hints at all these things of like my
baby likes roleplay even when he's like
messing like how when they're playing
the games how it keeps him away from
connecting with her in bed and that he
even so just joking by like humping him
yeah just like dudes messing with each
other but there's really oh well there's
also I mean so many little body language
cues too because I love the way Anthony
Mackie played the character cuz like a
number of tie I think I said it out loud
a couple of times cuz he just looked
like yeah a bit reserved and she says
that thing about like you know where do
you go sometimes you seem like you just
completely yes raw and I thought you did
a really good job embodying that before
the dialogue even confronts it you know
okay yeah just there's some great
dramatic scenes in here of conflict and
I like I love the world realized within
the game too because when I first starts
off you you are the two dudes going and
the way they bring the camera motion of
yeah I'm Mortal Kombat or a street
fighter type game to life was pretty
dazzling yeah when they over there
fighting each other yeah like no there's
so need man it was awesome this is kind
of a beautiful episode until a whole lot
of weird wave I don't know how to feel
like I have a hard time see I don't know
if the work for me would be beauty
there's buddy in there it's twisted I'm
still yeah I'm still so disturbed by the
whole conception in context of this
whole thing and she does say to him at
the restaurant you just got to tell me
what it is and I'll deal with it however
I got a deal with it and they do because
they're in their partnership there's no
there's just a lot of great they like
the writing it
one thing that black marriage
consistently impress is me on is they do
these like episodes that are not
connected and they have to fully realize
a new world every episode fully realized
brand new characters every episode as
essentially make things that are 20
minutes shorter than a movie and they
just and they know their world and their
character so goddamn well and they
usually follow the formula of who are
characters what's this new technology
set up here's how great the technology
set up is and now here's how it's gonna
destroy us yeah I'm sure is gonna take
this in wrong during usually the format
for a black mirror episode and I thought
this took it down a very different
weirdly more grounded approach because
it's not so much about look at the
technology it's more and like here's
what the technology is specifically
doing to us it is but it's also not yeah
yeah it's really just about these people
and like their lust you know yeah yeah
it's fascinating what if I really wonder
where the nugget of inspiration for this
particular episode came from because
yeah it is fascinating and I think it's
always special when they can mail a
blend of tones that is hard to describe
yes you know the way and and that really
does get under your skin and make you
squirm the whole episode is great
writing I really appreciated my heart
was beating I wanted to run around I had
that feeling of I don't want to watch
this episode I don't want to watch it
not because I hate and I got bored or
something I'm just this is way too close
for like I'm getting [ __ ] up in my
head right now I mean they make you feel
so terrible for for theof the whole time
but yes like stranded in the middle of
this and again like all the performances
but I thought especially hers for what
she had to do kind of removed from the
central part of the plot you know she ah
that's damn good television that is damn
good that's does damn good television
and I hope one of them gets Emmy
consideration so this one does yeah I
hope that I hope the writing of this
gets any consideration because this is
so so unique and it had every
opportunity to take a cliche route and
it did it until the up until the very
end and never took a cliche route well
that's that's something too is they have
managed because I think you pointed out
something
Stu twitch is there is kind of black
mirror formula or guide mark you know of
how episodes can go be cheap yeah yeah
yeah and I appreciate that at least this
didn't go yeah it didn't go where I
expected it to and it didn't go insane
or they were trapped in the game forever
yeah it wasn't the kind of [ __ ] up I
was imagining so like weird compromise
they made alright guys well should we
continue black mirror open share and
like this video I've heard you mean
you're telling me that like according to
like raw tomatoes or critics that's
generally the episodes go one two yeah
at least by this course yeah how people
receptive towards them subscribe
let's give a shout out I like to give a
patron add a shout-out to Taylor Bentley
oh hey what's up Taylor Bentley Taylor
Bentley has vanished on me I have
mentioned several times that he got a
girlfriend and I have never heard from
him since he got his girlfriend who
clearly stays pledged so he needs
striking cobras what I'm imagining is
that he's probably just that good in the
sack that his girlfriend won't even like
let him log on to look at porn or
something or we got it gets a tough
spawn to you yeah so we got to get some
like type of VR simulation going I got
to find out what the big deal is about
Taylor man cuz I got to experience the
Taylor love yeah you gotta get a love
making experience tailored to your
specific needs to my Bentley to your
Bentley and that is a high quality ride
right there
you made a work thanks thanks yeah no
problem